[Applause]
now
many of us are experts on something you
might know a lot about history science
or russian literature
but how much do you know about legendary
r b singer el debarge
let's find out in america's favorite
game show
know your l de barge
[Applause]
[Music]
the game is simple
the game is simple contestants compete
to find out who knows the most about pop
icon elder barge
our guests today are real life sisters
amber ruffin and lacey lamarr
yeah
now
amber and lacy are both lifelong elder
barge fans and they think they know more
about him than anyone in the world well
we're about to find out if that's true
please welcome our third contestant el
debarge
oh
[Applause]
wow
mr de barge yes sir thank you for being
here my pleasure my pleasure
now
for you folks at home
who are going through the sweats right
now
it may seem like we are setting up a
funny pre-written sketch we are not
this is real our contestants have never
heard these questions before and these
two sisters are out for blood that's
right so without further ado let's get
started first question
all right contestants
where
is el debarge from
oh amber detroit
okay let's ask the judges and the judges
are elder barge
[Applause]
the barge is that correct no yes it is
is correct
next question
finish this lyric
there she goes she knows i'm dying when
she says
okay lacey who is johnny
that is correct
all right
next up
next up
what movie featured the song rhythm of
the night
lacey again
no
last dragon
that is
correct
i froze or as we say in the black
community show enough
uh moving on
the song close to you is off what elder
barge album
lacy again that would be second chance
that would be correct
did you know that you beat me
[Applause]
[Laughter]
i don't know if you guys noticed they
are beating el debarge
like i stole something
okay all right
um i am uh going to play one second of
an elder bar song and all you have to do
is tell me the title all right here we
go
[Music]
[Applause]
my favorite song in the whole wide world
time will reveal
that
judge
uh for the white people and audience
that was smooth for correct
all right all right this next one is a
tough one
name every original member of the barge
oh my goodness okay amber oh
air the barge
randy
uh bunny
mark
and james
that
oh wait check with the judges dude i'm
gonna check with the judge judge is that
correct
i see
peaches
[Music]
yes that's correct that is correct all
right
i had to check myself now this question
is for everyone okay
what is the best elder bard song
lately i will reveal i just said it
earlier that is incorrect
amber uh close to you that is incorrect
um el debarge would you like to try all
of them
that is the correct answer
that's right
all the songs are perfect and we are
down to our last question and our last
question is just for elder barge
mr debarge
who loves you more amber or lacey
lacey
[Applause]
all right
and there's the buzzer
and the buzzer means we are out of time
and the winner is el debarge
[Applause]
for being patient enough
to put up with this nonsense thank you
all for playing join us next time for
no your l debarge
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you